what advice would you give yourself as a
20-year-old to give you the courage to
do as you've done to go into the
impossible and I asked Barry bar she's
80 years old I said Barry what would you
do he said I would make sure to tell my
20-year-old self to get over the
impostor syndrome um because I still
haven't gotten over it so what the hell
are you talking about you won the
freaking Nobel Prize you're among like
there's like there's more people in the
NBA right now Joe that are won the Nobel
Prize in physics that are alive okay
it's it's a very small group of people
people at most three people can win it
every year they typically win it when
they're in the 70s and 80s so their life
expens isn't like super s Rogers 92 now
but when you win it I said I said what
how could you possibly have the impostor
syndrome this fear of inadequacy that
you don't belong where you're at that
you don't deserve the accolades that you
had you won it it was selected by 400
nerds in Sweden that said you were good
enough to win the Nobel Prize how could
you he said no Brian when you win a
Nobel Prize you get the golden medal and
you get the million dollars or your your
portion of the million dollar purse but
they also want to make sure that you
that you received that you're not going
to come back later and say h where's my
Nobel Prize so they make you sign a
ledger they make you sign uh like
remember those oldfashioned autograph
books and uh they make you sign it and
he said Barry told me he said I'm a
curious guy so what do I do I look you
know who won it last year I saw some of
my friends and advisers maybe Richard
feeman wow that's pretty cool Marie cury
Albert Einstein his actual signature in
this book because it's only been around
for 116 years or something like that um
so a lot there you know goes back to
Einstein he won in
1922 when he saw Einstein he said I am
not worthy I'm just some humble kid from
you know Nebraska I don't belong here
how how could I possibly be in the same
book as Albert Einstein and I said Barry
I've got good news and I've got good
news I said did you know that um Albert
Einstein felt the impostor syndrome he's
like you're kidding me how could that
possibly be I said no he did I looked up
this quote and I showed it to him I said
Albert Einstein called Isaac Newton not
only the greatest scientist in history
but the man who single-handedly changed
Western Civilization more than any other
person through the pipia and the study
of of natural determinism and laws and I
said but wait there's more I said Newton
had the impostor syndrome who could he
have impostor syndrome about you might
wonder and if you read his writings do
you know what Isaac Newton the of
calculus the uh first person understand
universal gravitation discovered laws of
Optics do you know what his biggest
accomplishment according to him was what
he died a virgin yeah that was a weird
one right yeah I was going to bring that
up he was celibate you know why why
because there's only one way that he
could emulate his hero his the person
before whom he felt the impostor
syndrome and who was that that was Jesus
Christ oh boy so he wanted to be
Christlike he wanted to emulate Christ
and the only way he could do it he
couldn't like fast or I don't know he
couldn't bapti walk on water he couldn't
turn water into one he couldn't turn
loaves into fishes or whatever Jesus
also did but he could die cell it and
that's who he had impost are you sure he
just didn't was like an excuse for he
didn't like sex I don't know I mean it
sounds nutty because like how do you
figure that out 14 15 years old you know
you're young and full of hormones and
you've made this ision to be like Jesus
yeah yeah no it's uh he he was a strange
guy he sounds insane he definitely was
he was not like you would want to hang
out with Galo if you met want to hang
out with him too yeah for a little bit
just to see what it's like so when you
win the Nobel Prize you go there and
what is what is the Commandment about
idol worship it's that you shall make no
gilded golden Graven like engraved
images so who is that do you know who
that is uh Albert Noble yeah it's Alfred
Nobel that's right Alfred and you know
he invented Dynamite uh and he he also
died he died never having been married I
don't know if he was celibate or so he
was never married um but he uh he
established his PR when you win it you
literally the king of Sweden comes up to
you and you must bow down to him and he
puts the Gilded Graven image on your
head so for all the you know trappings
and all the 90% of National Academy
members who do not believe actively
profess a belief in God this can become
at some level a religion and it's a
kosher one it's okay to worship right
well the unattainable for that that's
maybe perhaps attainable to a very
select few is always the thing that
people are chasing after especially like
high Achievers that's right but many
many that I know that get there do have
impostor syndrome including MMA world
champions like some of them they get
there like this isn't real this can't be
real I can't be the man because they've
set this up their whole life and also
it's they look you can get to the
promised land but you can't stay in it
how many baseball teams have won
the World Series year after year forever
I mean even the Yankees haven't done
that even your BX haven't done that
right they're not mine okay fine